y
[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que aún nos
lleva a libia país que hace diez años
también vivió su revolución en el marco
de la llamada primavera árabe la caída
del régimen de muamar al gadafi tras 42
años en el poder
expuesto a las esperanzas de los libios
de tener un mejor futuro especialmente
para los más jóvenes quienes fueron los
que impulsaron las manifestaciones para
exigir libertad cambios políticos
económicos y sociales sin embargo hoy el
resultado no es el que se esperaba la
nación está más dividida que nunca entre
el este y el oeste y las heridas dejadas
por la guerra civil tardarán en sanar el
2011 un equipo de france 24 siguió a
sham y sus hombres en su batalla contra
las fuerzas de gadafi en las calles de
trípoli la capital libia una década
después nuestros reporteros no volvieron
a contactar para hablar de lo que ha
sucedido durante todo este tiempo y
saber si su lucha ha valido la pena
[Música]
cuando la revolución llegó estaba en
trípoli pero mi familia desde bengasi y
la revolución empezó allá entonces
decidimos ir para participar en ello y
no permanecer sentados expectantes es
uno de los momentos más bellos
ahora el país está dividido lo único que
falta es una línea que separe a ambos
lados es duro imaginar una
reconciliación que nos une
[Música]
estoy en bengasi desde 2018 y trabajo
para el canal ar jada
mi canal es reconocido por su apoyo al
ejército nacional libio dirigido por el
mariscal jalifa haftar y si se habla mal
de a alguien se puede tener problemas si
crees tele atención a sus preguntas no
se puede hablar libremente
y sabíamos que estaba aquí para volverse
otro dictador y media
[Música]
así haya transcurrido un decenio úsame
ya ir no ha vivido nada más fuerte que
aquella noche de 2011 tenía 32 años en
aquella época vivía en irlanda pero
decidió regresar a su país de origen
para luchar el rebelde se unió entonces
a la brigada trípoli tras un verano de
combate contra las tropas leales a
moamar gadafi el cerrojo se rompe sam y
sus hombres llegan a la capital libia
llegamos bajando por esta calle a lo que
en aquella época se llamaba la plaza
verde ahora la llamamos plaza de los
mártires diez años más tarde ver a toda
esta gente aquí es agradable
cuando llegamos a la entrada de la plaza
recuerdo que me dije libia es libre
mentalmente físicamente estoy destruido
pero por dentro grito de felicidad yo no
había dormido desde hacía tres días
entonces estaba hambriento y agotado ya
no tenía energía después de luchar
durante por lo menos 16 horas no estaba
concentrado para luchar cuando cayó la
plaza de los mártires sabíamos que el
final de gadafi estaba cerca
[Música]
ingresar a la plaza de los mártires hace
diez años fue sin duda el periodo más
intenso y más feliz de mi vida
hace 10 años inicialmente fue la
juventud educada de bengasi la que
encontró el coraje de rebelarse contra
el poder de gadafi la fiebre y la
euforia que se toman la gran ciudad del
este atrae hallada en ese entonces
estudiante en trípoli la joven mujer le
implora a su padre que la deje ir a
bengasi en aquella época cuando
estuvimos en bengasi le avisamos a mi
padre mi madre y yo si vamos allá no nos
quedaremos en casa queremos participar
ir a la calle vamos a protestar y fue lo
que ocurrió
[Música]
fuimos a la calle y nos dimos cuenta de
que había un lugar para las mujeres
manifestantes y otro para las ondas mi
madre y yo nos volvimos en alguna medida
encargadas de este lugar y organizamos
las manifestaciones sentíamos que
teníamos voces
que contábamos por primera vez el nivel
después de bengasi las ciudades del
oeste del país se sublevan mohamed el
bibi viene de misrata a sus 16 años toma
las armas para defender su ciudad que
resiste frente a las tropas del régimen
hoy se reúne con sus compañeros de armas
ubicados cerca a 110 años antes es en
esta ciudad que el niño rebelde se cruza
con gadafi el guía libio está huyendo
abandona su pistola de oro en un
vehículo
mohamed la toma justo antes de la
captura del dictador
cuando tuve la pistola en mis manos hubo
muchos tiros no entendíamos nada pero
cuando vimos la multitud tratamos de
entender lo que ocurría y supimos el
arresto de gadafi
una gran alegría para mí la alegría fue
aún mayor por haber tomado dicha pistola
creíamos que con el arresto de gadafi y
su hijo la guerra terminaría en libia
nos imaginábamos viviendo una vida feliz
nos dijeron que libia sería como dubai
pero no hemos visto nada nada ha
cambiado
de hecho empeora
[Música]
a continuación
la guerra civil no ha cesado libia está
dividida en dos desde la llegada al
poder del mariscal estar en el este en
2014 en tarun a 60 kilómetros al sur de
trípoli varias fosas comunes fueron
descubiertas el verano pasado la ciudad
servía de base militar para los hombres
de ajustar durante su asalto a la
capital fue una derrota antes de huir de
la ciudad estos milicianos asesinaron
hombres mujeres y niños en la alcaldía
de tal una las familias aportan fotos de
sus familiares con la esperanza de que
sean identificados sus hijos fueron
secuestrados delante de ellos a los
funcionarios locales les resulta difícil
escuchar el relato de esos días de
venganza
pues a él no le pido nada
no quiero dinero no me importa solo
quiero a mis hijos como se llama el el
es mohamed jones al limo qatar qué edad
tiene él nació en el 2000 y él en el
2002 entonces 21 años llegaron dos en
plena noche yo golpearon la puerta vi a
un hombre decir dónde están tus hijos
azul en el prat
dije qué quiere decir
mis hijos están durmiendo están
durmiendo abrí la ventana y me di cuenta
que había bloqueado el barrio entendí
quién era ingresaron a todas las casas
uy tumbaron la puerta rompieron la
puerta y se llevaron a mis hijos
les juro que dormían estaban en llamas
bajo sus cobijas los sacaron de su
habitación a un lobo ya o jalarlo de la
camiseta y yo gritaba por qué
son mis hijos que hicieron y me dijeron
no debemos interrogarnos
son mis hermanos todos fueron asesinados
ya no tengo hermanos tomaron sus bienes
saquearon sus casas dejaron a sus hijos
traumatizados este dejó cuatro hijos el
otros siete hijos y el otro 4
los dos últimos debían casarse estos
criminales robaron su felicidad captar
haftar el criminal captar el criminal de
guerra muslo no hay gobierno en el este
sólo hay una máquina asesina criminal
bengasi no es una ciudad de paz como
dicen
bengasi es una ciudad de terror dominada
por la fuerza una ciudad de asesinato
los miembros de la milicia alcan y
responsables de las masacres de tar una
se refugiaron en bengasi la gran ciudad
costera del este de libia aún está
traumatizada por la guerra contra el
autodenominado grupo estado islámico el
oeste del país no vivió la ocupación
yihadista afrontándolos el mariscal
califa haftar se impuso en este lugar
los periodistas no trabajan libremente
en bengasi lo que desea mostrar el bando
de captar ese orden y disciplina el
colegio militar forma a los futuros
oficiales de la nl el autoproclamado
ejército nacional libio apoyado por el
vecino egipcio y por rusia
cuando el director menciona el año de la
revolución piensa
[Música]
en la caída del ejército de las
instituciones y el aparato de seguridad
del país según las instrucciones del
estado mayor así descubrió militar fue
creado
colegio militar recibe alumnos de 18 a
23 años
pasan a crecer sin sanar
muchos jóvenes reclutas se alistaron
después de la guerra contra el grupo
estado islámico aquí en el extremo más
afectado por los hermanos musulmanes y
los extremistas tenemos miembros de
nuestras familias y personas cercanas
que fueron asesinadas en esta guerra
entonces decidimos integrar el ejército
de la sangre de los mártires que se
sacrificaron no sea desperdiciada y
nosotros somos la nueva sangre inyectada
en las filas del ejército y esa nueva
sangre será mejor que la anterior
nuestro lema se gana o se muere
a través del entrenamiento siempre para
su psicología para el sacrificio y la
entrega a la patria
la división del país también se ve aquí
una herida para estos jóvenes
para la saca
lo que me hace más daño es todo lo que
nosotros los jóvenes perdimos desde 2011
la bendición del país entre el este y el
oeste es duro para mí ver a mi país
es más difícil tengo familia me molesta
y la situación hace que no pueda
hablarles lente frente visitables
desde hace cinco años hablamos por
teléfono de lejos
espero que el ejército gane y libia este
mundo
[Música]
esta fractura entre el este y el oeste
del país explica el recorrido de atún en
el sur cada día presenta los noticieros
del canal al hayat dirigido por los
militares
joven revolucionario en 2011
ahmet fue detenido por una milicia de
trípoli apoyada por turquía una vez
afuera de prisión decide irse al este
fui torturado golpeado insultado por
este grupo armado
tras la intervención de amigos y vecinos
fue liberado en trípoli
decidí abandonar las actividades
políticas en esta ciudad dirigida por
las milicias pero en bengasi no fue el
caso decidí continuar con mi camino y
apoyar lo que consideramos como una
causa sagrada desde entonces no volvió a
ver a su familia que se quedó en trípoli
le preguntamos si podría ir
es imposible es imposible que vaya
me tendrán en el aeropuerto me llevarán
a una base militar desafortunadamente
los jóvenes están perdidos entre las
guerras los conflictos y la división
política actual
[Música]
regreso al frente de sirte donde las
fuerzas del oeste y las del este se
observan estamos en periodo de cese al
fuego cada uno se apega a las tareas
cotidianas esperando las órdenes una
vida entre hombres echa más de
aburrimiento que de batallas que
persigue a sus combatientes desde la
revolución de contra
el ingeniero en la compañía petrolera
agua en 2011
de hecho lo olvidamos todo durante la
guerra nuestros estudios precedentes y
nuestra experiencia laboral lo olvidamos
todo
no tenemos la suerte de casarse
salsa aquí cada uno quisiera casarse y
tener hijos perspectivas pero nadie está
casado cada año o año y medio comienza
una nueva guerra no quiere imponerle a
una mujer vivir conmigo en mi casa y
tener que irme al frente en trípoli
conoce donde dejándola sola no lo sé no
es posible
yo quiero irme a estudiar al extranjero
para obtener un máster o un doctorado y
volver al país con una mejor educación
que le aprovecha el país y el mundo en
general
[Música]
abandonar libia un sueño compartido por
la juventud del oeste y del este en el
puerto de trípoli aquella noche tiene
lugar la inauguración de una exposición
montada por chad allá y sus amigos desde
hace semanas ella que siempre se negó a
abandonar libia es casi que una
excepción
la mayoría de mis amigos se fueron en
2014 soy la única ya no me sentía en
casa porque todos mis amigos se habían
ido
pero después de 2016 la vida mejor
bueno no es mejor a veces las carreteras
están cortadas no sé por qué razón a
veces no hay electricidad red internet
pero seguimos trabajando no tiene
sentido para mucha gente pero tratamos
de hacer frente
[Música]
es casi una obligación hacer frente
obstinarse recordar de dónde se viene y
aferrarse a este estrecho espacio de
libertad conquistado con esfuerzo hace
diez años
llegamos al final de boleto de vuelta a
libia recuerde que si quiere ver esto y
otros contenidos en español puede
visitar nuestra página web france24
puntocom hasta pronto